[Music]
it's the same technique leg trumpet but
you don't have any buttons to press you
only have to do it with your mouth and
with your air
[Music]
I'm Tim Ninh I'm 16 years old and I play
in the airport I started when I was six
years old my father's Chinese and my
mother is from B ellos but I am born in
Germany and the iron is not common there
sometimes people come to me and ask me a
lot of Christian for example where are
you from and why do you play the eye
porn
for some people it's really crazy for me
I play with heart I love this instrument
and that music the village drink pure
Festival Ananda is an international
meeting for album players the best
players in the world come here to
compete and last year I won the first
prize in juice category at the Aipom
festival other things are here Forks
dancing some kind of wrestling but the
most important thing here is to play the
iPhone
most of the players are from Swiss but
there are people who come from Japanese
Germany like me or the USA during the
competition the jury is blind so they
sit in a tent and see nothing they only
hear when I play how do you describe I
feel lucky I feel like yeah to play in
the mountains it's a great experience
because nobody has such a view
[Music]
box wars really feels like a medieval
battle the only difference is this with
cardboard
[Music]
[Applause]
there's rules to box wars but they're
very limited there's no winners we like
to say that if you're in a box war is
bad you've already lost I'm Ross I'm one
of the supreme overlords of box Wars box
Wars is a collective of people that love
to get together create cardboard
creations and then destroy them in an
epic battle it's more about
competitiveness in being creative the
only materials that you can use
cardboard adhesives like tape hot glue
whatever you can find in packaging
that's the stuff that we like to use to
build our suits every single battle has
a new engineering challenge like
building a giant aircraft carrier or
building a monster truck that actually
rolls or a train which has to carry in a
whole bunch of policemen we encourage
people to come down to our events and
build as elaborate costumes as they can
possibly make
once they've build the props then we all
gather at a park and then we battle
everyone comes in and clashes and
destroys everything stuff that we've
spent weeks on designing it's all gone
in seconds it just started off really
small but then all the sudden it blew up
there's generally around about 50 to 100
people in the actual battle and then it
can be hundreds and hundreds of
spectators we've got chapters that have
started up all around the world we've
had groups in Japan in Europe in America
in Canada it seems so childish but it's
fantastic without a concept like this
crosses cultural and language barriers
Vauxhall's is based around comedy that's
the whole point of box wars we're losers
what we're doing is quite pathetic we
should all have real jobs but here we
are building stuff out of cardboard if
you laugh at us that's exactly what we
want
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my name is Tony peacock Robbie Goodman
my name is Sheila fry
I am a ten times six time two-time champ
of the national Hollerin contest or
Spivey's corner North Carolina
Hollerin is a controlled sound that
farmers used to communicate with one
another before they had modern
conveniences like electricity or
telephone haulers had a certain rhythm
and a modulation that would create an
echo that would travel over a long
distance but there isn't just one type
of holler
there are actually four types of hollers
number one functional it serves a
purpose such as calling down to a field
or calling up from a field when you
needed something number two
communicative you're communicating a
message such as good morning good
evening number three distress you need
help
number four expressive just for sheer
fun many times that could be in the form
of tunes or Diddy's these types of
hollers were what the judges were
looking for at the National hollering
contest the first ever national
hollering contest was in 1969 it was
started to raise funds for the local
fire department it became a nationwide
here hey that's me I won the Junior
Division in 1978 my horror was a
distress holler it sounded like a siren
everybody had their own twisted they put
on the National Hollerin contest ran for
about 48 years till 2015 we created the
worldwide hollering festival that's
located in hope meals to try to preserve
and keep the tradition of hollering
their life Hollerin is an important
piece of culture in this region because
it helps us remember our past we can
also appreciate the modern conveniences
we have today Hollerin is part of
simpler times and it's just something
that we need to treasure because we need
to know our history
I love hollering cause it brings the
community together than just the
fellowship that you have with one
another we want to keep that tradition
alive
[Music]
[Music]
we didn't really have any fast actors
from Texas until he came along like I
can't really believe my eyes
like I was in shock his hands like they
were always moving and it was like there
was no like thinking about where to put
it it was just like a non-stop just like
put it he's off the charts he's like as
fast as a lightning bolt
[Music]
my name is Trey Griffith and I'm the
fastest cup sector in the state of Texas
my goal is to be the fastest cup sucker
in the whole entire world when I first
saw Trey begin cups tacky I was thrilled
kids on the spectrum are always very
passionate and very intense on what
their fixation is and he just shined I
mean you could see that he was in his
element he was comfortable he was alive
and he was just doing his thing
Trey took it to a completely different
level he was doing it systematically
instead of just kind of for fun and it
was all about getting that next best
time what Trey does in five or six
seconds takes me 10 or 12 13 seconds
we've learned not to ever discount what
he says he's gonna do Sport Stacking
is using a set of 12 plastic cups and
you stack them in a very specific
sequence of pyramids and you are racing
yourself and you're racing a time
it's a sport that you don't have to be
tall you don't have to necessarily be
able to run quickly as long as you've
got the 12 cups you've got Matt and
you've got a timer you can stack to me
it's just mind-boggling to see these
stackers like Trey his friends and you
can tell they're not even looking at the
cups that they're stacking it is all
muscle memory
I mean it's so fast when they get to
this level that the naked eye cannot see
it all when I found out that I was
having a boy of course I thought about
when I was a boy and playing catch with
my dad in the backyard and you flash
forward you know thinking about those
types of things with your kid out but
when Trey found stacking it's like okay
cool
here's a sport that he's into and it's
got speed I've always loved sports with
speed and it's got rhythms which make
him happy and I realized what a better
way to bond with my child than to learn
how to stock myself I get to stand next
to my son who's one of the fastest in
the world and stack with him and be a
part of something special
watching the two of them stacked
together are probably some of the best
moments I've ever had our motto has
always been the family that stacks
together stays together
and we'd go to these tournaments
together we traveled together we've made
friends all over the country all over
the world I mean it's definitely
enriched our lives
you
[Music]